hey Mon I'm a t-shirt welcome to Abby's
kitchen we are officially in holiday
entertaining mode so I partnered with my
friends at Eve's who sponsored this
video to help you whip up a plant-based
spread that everyone is gonna love if
you're stumped on what to serve your
plant-based guests this holiday let me
tell you something the temps to go over
really well with pretty much everyone
carbs
I am no vegan I definitely believe this
a lot of value to adding more
plant-based meals to our usual routine
and carbs are the holiday king I will
pretty much always forego the turkey
roast beefs ham or other holiday beast
in order to dig into a big bowl of
creamy pasta soaked up with some crusty
bread so today I want to share with you
my crowd-pleasing vegan creamy mushroom
and caramelized onion pasta made extra
meaty thanks to Eve's original veggie
ground round this meat swap tastes and
feels just like me so it's a hundred
percent carnivore approved but it's even
easier to prepare making it a really
convenient source of protein for this
hectic holiday season and with this
cream free cream sauce sweet caramelized
onions and hearty mushrooms even the
hardcore meat lovers at the buffet are
not going to be able to refuse let's do
this
make my sauce I heat 2 tablespoons of
olive oil over medium low heat and a
large skillet and add my sliced onions
cook them until they reach a dark amber
color about 45 to 60 minutes
next I add in my mushrooms and cook
until lightly browned about 7 minutes
next I add in the Eve's original veggie
ground round garlic and thyme and I
saute until the garlic is fragrant and
the veggie ground brown is crumbled next
to the bowl I mixed together the Amin
milk and flour then I add that to the
pan over medium heat allow the sauce to
cook until it thickens about 4 minutes
and I pour in the almond creamer and
season the sauce with salt and pepper to
taste
next I cook my pasta according to the
box directions and then to make the
crumb topping I heat 2 teaspoons of oil
over medium heat along with the garlic
and panko cook just until the panko
starts to brown to assemble the pasta I
add my pasta to the sauce and toss
everything to coat
[Music]
surfeit up top cause vegan parmesan
[Music]
garlic bread crumbs parsley and thyme
enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
so whether you got vegans at the holiday
table or you're just trying to get a
little bit more balance in your holiday
menu
I'm sure this past dish is gonna become
an instant family favorite thank you
again so much to east for sponsoring
this video
if you loved it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below some
of your family's favorite meatless
holiday recipes subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Abbey's
kitchen bye
[Music]